[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après ce contact en apparence banale un
coup d'épaule à la poitrine démarre
emline se relève puis s'effondre
ça fait plus de 25 ans que le monde j'ai
jamais été témoin quelque chose comme ça
joueur des Alouettes monsieur prout
faisait l'analyse du match sur les ondes
de RDS qui s'est levé puis est tombé
comme il est tombé comme un boxeur était
passé le chaos déjà à ce moment-là
quelques secondes après on se dit que
c'était pas normal
les soigneurs se précipitent pour
pratiquer des manœuvres de réanimation
sur le jeune homme de 24 ans son pot est
rétabli avec un défibrillateur c'est le
choc et la stupeur sur le terrain alors
que ses coéquipiers prient pour lui le
maraudeur des bises de baffleau est
transporté à l'hôpital le match est
suspendu
[Musique]
on pense que démarre emline aurait été
victime d'une commotion cardiaque un
événement extrêmement rare le choc qu'il
a reçu aurait entraîné un arrêt du cœur
c'est pas comme un du tout qu'on voit
des choses comme ça mais ça arrive quand
on a un coup précisément de au cash
thoracique directement au-dessus du cœur
ça doit s'arriver quand le cœur est en
train de se rit pour la viser dans
quelques millisecondes où ça se parait
ici arrive un choc important exactement
à ce moment-là le cœur développe une
arythmie complètement désorganisé le
qu'on appelle la fibrillation
ventriculaire et qui en fait c'est
synonyme en fait du mort subite mais
grâce à l'intervention rapide des
secours le joueur des Bills pourrait
s'en remettre sans trop de séquelles le
plus rapidement qu'on peut utiliser une
défibrillateur pour choquer le cœur pour
le remettre en rythme normal c'est ça
qui va prédire si quelqu'un a une
récupération totale ou non c'est fort
possible qu'il aura une récupération
totale il est jeune il pas de problème
médicaux de ce qu'on sache
c'est un bâton ils s'en sortira d'une de
ses amis
[Musique]
les partisans sont derrière lui comme en
témoigne ses images
autre preuve de solidarité les dons
affluent à la Fondation mise sur pied
par des marrelin pour distribuer des
jouets aux enfants pauvres plus de 4
millions de dollars ont été amassés
depuis hier il s'olivier Bachard
Radio-Canada Montréal